today's sponsor is blue Chu and they're
giving you your first shipment totally
free all you have to do is pay five
dollars for shipping go to blue chewed
comm use promo code David I've put the
link right underneath this video so
today I thought we'd take a little bit
of a deeper look at Joe Biden's 2020
platform and I don't just want to read
through his positions what I want to do
is pick a few areas and think about
whether Joe Biden's ideas whether Joe
Biden's policy positions his policy
prescriptions is platform would Joe
Biden's policy ideas really deal with
root problems or would they fix symptoms
of a problem and I want to make a couple
of things clear number one we have a
system that incentivizes dealing with
symptoms and not problems when you're in
Congress you have a reelection every two
years and you have to justify being
reelected presidents have four-year
terms
senators six but of course it's much
more difficult to get big things done
sometimes in the Senate depending on
what type of thing you're talking about
although that doesn't always apply so we
fundamentally have a system that
encourages not really dealing with the
systemic problems which often take more
than two or four years to deal with but
rather dealing with symptoms or even
appearing to deal with symptoms without
actually dealing with them so we're
going to talk about that now a few
important things to think about one is
I'm going to go by Joe Biden's stated
2020 platform now there are going to be
people who write to me and say I don't
believe that Joe Biden actually wants to
do X or Y even though he claims he does
listen to some extent no president does
what they promised and every candidate
states that they will try to do things
that are very difficult to do or almost
impossible to do look at Donald Trump's
presidency for an example but this is a
pointless exercise if we're simply going
to say oh here's Joe's list of stuff he
wants to do I think he's just lying okay
I mean listen to that's it's it's
impossible to defeat that argument if
you want to insist on making it number
two some of you might say well why
aren't you talking about by
wanting to cut social security again I'm
going by Biden's 2020 platform in the
90s Joe Biden said he would consider
putting social security cuts on the
table if a proposal otherwise made sense
to him it was 25 years ago it's not part
of his platform today there's no real
reason to include that in his platform
because it's simply not lastly when I
talk about solving a problem versus
dealing with a symptom let's use an
example from the Trump presidency Trump
believes the solution to undocumented
immigration is to build a wall across
the entire us-mexico border
building a wall at best deals with a
symptom right the wall would potentially
slow down the portion of people coming
to the US illegally by physically
crossing the us-mexico land border
that's a symptom of the problem to solve
the actual problem you would have to
deal with number one the economic
conditions in Latin America that lead
people to want to come to the United
States illegally in the first place you
would have to deal with more strictly
punishing or punishing at all companies
that hire undocumented immigrants
because as long as companies keep doing
that and not being punished they're
going to continue doing it and number
three you would also have to account for
the higher prices that would come on
many products if indeed you routed out
all undocumented labor in the United
States so building the wall maybe
address as part of one symptom but it
does nothing to deal with the problem
that's the type of thinking that we want
to do here I'm not gonna do all of Joe
Biden's positions but let's do some of
the key things will start with criminal
justice on criminal justice Joe Biden
wants to eliminate mandatory minimum
sentences eliminate private prisons end
the cocaine sentencing disparity and the
cash bail system and eliminate the death
penalty so to answer whether this deals
with the problem or just symptoms you
have to understand what the problem is
I would generalize the problem with our
justice system including the courts and
criminal justice system as we have a
two-tiered system one for the rich and
one for the poor with a heavily
racialized component and a for-profit
component that has no business being
there and it is at its core a system
that has folk
seeing too much on street crime and not
enough on corporate and white-collar
crime so when I look at what Joe Biden
wants to do on criminal justice I would
say that this is somewhere in the middle
between fixing symptoms and dealing with
the problem
Biden goes directly at some elements of
the problem so ending cash bail and
private prisons that deals with the
for-profit component of the problem but
the problem is way bigger and this
proposal from Joe Biden does nothing
about setting priorities in terms of
street crime versus corporate and
white-collar crime doesn't address that
at all
Biden also is not in favor of
legalization of cannabis that is a
massive criminal justice issue and he is
not in favor of it so I would say that
Biden on criminal justice he's just
passed dealing with only symptoms
towards getting at some of the problems
but it doesn't do nearly enough now by
the way this is Trump's a disaster so
this is not a comparison with Trump I
want to make that really clear next
let's look at the economy Joe Biden on
the economy okay what is Joe Biden's
economic policy Joe Biden wants a $15 an
hour minimum wage he wants paid family
in sick leave a 1.3 trillion dollar
infrastructure package roll back the
Trump tax cuts meaning raised the top
rate from 37 to 39 point six percent
extend the payroll tax to $400,000
currently that caps out at about a
hundred and thirty eight thousand raise
the corporate tax rate from 21 to 28
percent tax capital gains and dividends
as ordinary income after 1 million
dollars a year and then put a fifteen
percent minimum tax on large companies
to prevent them from using loopholes and
deductions to end up paying zero so here
Biden starts to get at some of the
actual economic problems in this country
inequality a system designed to allow
you to pay less and less as a percentage
of what you earn as you have more and
more this applies to rich individuals
and corporations as well so Biden is
getting at some of the fundamental
problems here now what Biden doesn't
deal with
in terms of problems are the absolutely
sky-high costs of living in much of the
country 15 bucks an hour it's great but
it's not a living wage in much of the
country doesn't deal with guaranteeing a
living wage doesn't deal with the
loopholes that are disproportionately
used by the super-rich so for example
taking the payroll tax threshold up to
four hundred thousand this year it's a
hundred and thirty seven thousand seven
hundred that hits people earning between
a hundred and thirty seven K and four
hundred K but then it goes away and we
can have a debate over what's right and
what's fair and what's economically
sensible but the point is if you're
above four hundred thousand a year in
income you're unaffected by that and the
ultra-rich who are really benefiting
from a lot of the loopholes and
mechanisms that exist there earning way
more than four hundred thousand dollars
a year
another example the top tax bracket
would go back to thirty nine point six
percent under Joe Biden that's what it
was before Donald Trump okay great but
that doesn't go nearly high enough and
we need we need higher and more tax
brackets we probably need there's a
bunch of proposals but we probably need
like a forty two percent tax bracket at
a million and then we would go to a
forty eight percent okay so we need more
brackets and they need to go higher
Biden does a little bit but he's not
really dealing with it at a more core
issue which is the ultra ultra rich that
as a percentage of their total income
are actually paying lower rates but
there is some good stuff in there and
night and day compared to Trump I mean
truly night and day in short Biden's
economic policy platform is a completely
predictable uncontroversial moderately
left proposal it deals with symptoms it
gets some problems but it doesn't do
nearly enough it's way better than Trump
let's do one more area for today which
is health care this is obviously huge
Biden on health care he has said that he
supports lowering the Medicare age from
65 to 60 would create a public option
would give free access to the public
option if you're in a state that didn't
do the Medicaid
and that was part of Obamacare there are
Republican governors who said okay
Obamacare includes this Medicaid
expansion but we're not going to do it
if you are in one of those states you
would get free access to the public
option even if your state didn't do the
expansion based on income up to one
hundred and thirty eight percent of the
federal poverty level that's like five
million people and then Biden would also
increase tax credits by eliminating the
four hundred percent poverty level cap
and limiting the total out-of-pocket
cost to eight point five percent of
income that would be down from close to
ten percent and the credits would be
based on gold plans rather than I don't
remember if it's bronze or silver
currently that raises the amount of the
credits and then Biden with limit launch
prices and price increases on drugs as
well as allow foreign drug purchases so
there's a lot there it is not Medicare
for all it is not Universal there's no
doubt about it what are the numbers that
that this would achieve if you lower the
Medicare age from 65 to 60 I believe it
adds 18 million people to Medicare I I
don't have that number in front of me
and I had a little trouble finding it
but going from memory I believe it's
about 18 or 20 million more people that
would get Medicare by lowering the age
from 65 to 60 it's not universal but you
know a lot of people a free public
option in states without Medicaid
expansion would add again about five
million four point nine million people
and then there are certainly millions
more that would be able to afford health
insurance with this is it a panacea of
course not of course not is it better
than Trump's proposal with Republicans
which would have seen 24 to 32 million
more people lose insurance of course
it's better than that the symptoms are
care is too expensive it's sometimes low
quality and it's not accessible to
everyone in large part because of the
for-profit system that we have this
biden's plan changed the problem of
healthcare being for-profit of course
not he doesn't believe that's the
problem that's a major disagreement
right now even within the Democratic
Party Biden deals substantively with
symptoms and the
way he does it is you get care to more
people and you make it affordable for
more people
but not everyone so let's step back a
little bit to sum up we have a system
that encourages at a fundamental level
because of the frequency of Elections
how politics is financed needing to
raise money etc and how long things take
to get done we have a system that
incentivizes appearing to deal with
symptoms sometimes you're actually
dealing with a symptom sometimes you're
only appearing to and optics very much
are the only thing that actually matters
when Congress is up for re-election
every two years when presidents get
four-year terms we have to understand
the difficulty in a system like that of
dealing with problems this doesn't
excuse candidates or presidents who
don't do it and it doesn't encourage
only dealing with symptoms we just have
to understand that reality Trump by and
large has identified the wrong symptoms
and is dealing with them in a completely
farcical way that's how I would sum it
up Joe Biden would actually deal with
these symptoms in a way that would
function reasonably well but would only
start to get at the underlying problems
that's my assessment on health care
economy and criminal justice we could
look at environment and others and maybe
we will do so let me know what you think
about this framework of symptoms versus
problems I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
we'll take a quick break and so much on
today's program the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
this episode was sponsored by blue Chu
giving my viewers their first shipment
totally free when you go to blue to calm
and use promo code David it's just a
reality that many men regardless of age
can sometimes benefit from a boost in
confidence a little bit of performance
help blue chew is the first chewable
tablet with the same fda-approved
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis blue to
being a chewable tablet means it starts
working twice as fast as a pill it's
prescribed online you spend a couple
minutes with a short questionnaire a
licensed doctor reviews the information
decides if a prescription is right for
you it's then shipped directly to your
home in discreet packaging no awkward
visits to the doctor's office or
pharmacy plus it's also cheaper than
getting it at a pharmacy when you go to
blue to calm and use promo code David
you will get your first shipment
completely free just pay $5 shipping
that's promo code David you get your
first shipment of blue two completely
free and I've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome back to the very big
thank you to today's new members of the
day bob Gillingham and william Bennion
bob and william really appreciate your
support also want to say thanks to
today's longtime sustaining member of
the day that's Linda Taylor Linda's been
a member since 2015 almost five years of
membership for Linda
you can join these great people
membership is the primary funding source
for the show the number one funding
source for the show and you can
subscribe in almost under a minute I
think for most people it is under a
minute at join pakman.com coupon code
this is 20 20 saves you 40% all right
back after a couple of weeks of hiatus
is hate reott mail what is hatred mail
it is when a professional voice-over
artist does interpretive readings of the
hate mail that I receive here's a quick
reminder why don't you take some
hydroxychloroquine for that trump
derangement syndrome patriot mail
written by patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom all right a lot in this week's
hatred mail
let's listen to it first and then
discuss and think about it nice yarmulke
David of course Pakman is a Jew Hispanic
is not a race it is an ethnicity and
you're Jewish but Argentina white boy
get the Jews out seriously David Pakman
is a Jew a denier of Christ don't be a
greedy Jew and use your dog as a ploy
come on bro we're better than that as
progressives so Hispanic is not a race
but rather an ethnicity but I'm Jewish
but I'm from Argentina so I'm a white
boy but Jews should leave well I guess
if Jews are white then I don't need to
leave it's kind of a weird amalgam of
xenophobia and various misunderstandings
I love the we're better than that as
progressives the viewer I guess sort of
implying that they are part of the
progressive crowd just another
progressive who says Jews get out yeah
somehow I think that this person may be
gaslighting and what I want to remind
you is the best way to fight hate reott
ISM is to use the coupon code hate reott
40 when you get a membership at join
pakman.com h 8e r io t 4 0 you save 40%
and hatreds cry every time that coupon
code is used at join pakman.com as many
of you may know I've mentioned I've been
listening to the Howard Stern Show for
more than 20 years and he has had
recently increasingly interesting
comments about Donald Trump including
this week and the the back story is that
Donald Trump and Howard Stern sort of
used to be acquaintances I don't know
that I'd say friends but Donald Trump
would regularly appear on Howard Stern's
show for years he would say many
outrageous things he would rate women on
scales from one to ten you know all
sorts of different stuff they don't talk
anymore Howard Stern vociferous Lee
supported Hillary Clinton in 2016 and
from what I gather Trump and Howard
Stern have not spoken since that time
and Howard Stern had an interesting take
about the relationship between Trump and
his own supporters when he did a show
earlier this week on Sirius XM radio and
the gist of it is that Trump supporters
are mostly people that Trump despises
bearing in mind that Donald Trump grew
up rich in New York and his supporters
overwhelmingly are the types of folks
that Trump would never want at
mar-a-lago or at his own hotels or
around him or whatever the case may be
that that is the constituency that has
disproportionately made up Trump's base
rural white Midwestern and southern
Americans for example I think you get
the gist of it but not doesn't apply to
everybody but let's check out the
comments and then discuss the oddity in
all of this is the people Trump despises
most love him the most think about it
the the the people who are voting for
Trump for the most part they're not
people he wants oh my god he wouldn't
even know I'm in a hotel he be disgusted
with them he doesn't want to you go look
at mar-a-lago see if there's any people
that look like you I'm talking to you in
the audience that the Trump voter who
you know idolizes the guy he disappears
you despises you you're someone to grab
by the [ __ ] if you're hot
I know Donnell I know very well
and I don't hate Donald I hate you for
voting for him I don't hate Donald
battles doing his thing I hate you from
voting for him for not having an Indian
intelligence not a mitt let's see what's
going on with the coronavirus not able
to see what the Justice Department is
doing I hate you
don't want you here I want to build a
wall and throw you out
I do I'm for a wall
the Mexican for you
that's how I feel now don't call me and
start arguing with me Howard you're a
jerk you're a Libertad or whatever it is
you call I ain't no lip tar trust me I'm
hardly a liberal
hardly you have no idea how no
non-liberal I am this is pretty spot-on
in some ways in the sense that they just
don't get it it is true that the Trump
voter typically just doesn't get it but
this is not unique to Donald Trump and I
think it bears a little more exploration
and to understand this you have to think
about personal versus in-group
priorities personal versus in-group
frameworks the 2010 Tea Party is an
example that I've talked about before
social psychologist Jonathan Hite talked
about this we interviewed him on the
program year or so ago maybe a little
longer and he's written about this
extensively he wrote about it in the
book the righteous mind which Eve you
don't have to agree with everything that
Jonathan height writes but and I don't
agree with it 100% but he writes about
this extensively and the gist is when
you look at individual versus group
framing there is a very long history of
people acting in ways that don't seem to
be optimized at their individual level
but are optimized for their group and as
a result they perceive that it will
confer benefits to them and the best way
to think about it is with an example um
you look at the 2010 Tea Party all right
2010 Tea Party ran on lower taxes for
the rich don't tread on me right so
lower government regulations lower
government involvement don't regulate
business nearly as much essentially
allow more pollution lower fuel
efficiency standards more oil drilling
fewer welfare benefits and social
programs you look at who was
overwhelmingly supporting the Tea Party
you look at the districts where the Tea
Party candidate won sometimes against an
incumbent sort of more traditional
Republican it was overwhelmingly people
who were never going to be rich and
benefit from those tax cuts for the rich
whose taxes weren't going to go down if
Tea Partiers got their way who live in
places that would be ravaged by the very
industrial pollution that the Tea Party
would have allowed by eliminating
government regulations and taking this
Lizz affair more libertarian approach so
you might be able to just simply say
we're on the Left we we we understand
what these dumb people don't these are
just stupid people tricked
into voting against their own best
interests and that is so the wrong
approach they may have been tricked but
it's not that they don't understand the
policies of the Tea Party they
understand in many cases what the
policies are they've identified that
those are the policies that their group
favors even if they don't immediately
see or believe that at any point they
will personally benefit they believe
that there will be a sort of
trickle-down benefit because this is
what their group wants and that is why
they are voting for these policies by
voting for the Tea Party they may not
even know why they may not realize that
their group has actually been taken over
by elites who want to use them as a tool
to achieve what's good for them rather
than for the actual voters who are just
gonna get peanuts or crumbs but they
understand the policies and in many
cases they've identified the policies as
this is what our team or our group wants
and I'm going to vote with the orthodoxy
of the group I'm a part of apply that to
the Trump voter and you see that there's
a similarity in many cases we've
categorized Trump voters before some of
them don't actually understand what from
brunt ran on they don't they have no
clue what the policies are or they don't
understand them could be because of
cognitive limitations it could be people
who lack education and critical thinking
skills simply people who don't watch the
news and just sort of like herd vote for
Donald Trump there's people who voted
for Trump because they have a limited
understanding of the facts but a lot of
Trumpets do understand the policies of
Trump and even if they don't see how it
helps them specifically they're part of
the group except that the people really
in Trump's group which is what Howard
Stern points out are people who hang out
at mar-a-lago and a lot of these Trump
supporters I would say the overwhelming
majority are people that pre politics
Trump would never be associated with
would be seen as would be seeing as
people that are fundamentally beneath
him most Trump voters are people Trump
wouldn't be caught dead with except as
part of a photo-op or rally now that
he's a politician now where I disagree
with Howard Stern is this entire you
know I hate his
orders for voting for him and their
their dumb that's an understandable
visceral reaction particularly when you
see the way that Donald Trump's
presidency has ravaged so many aspects
of society and culture and the economy
and the u.s. standing around the world
and on and on and on but as a practical
matter it falls under the umbrella of
what I'd call vote shaming and it's it's
plenty interesting to do for a broadcast
show and it's it's compelling and
salacious but I don't think it's a good
way to get people to reconsider their
votes now at the same time I don't think
that Trump is going to be defeated by
convincing his supporters not to vote
for him I've said before I don't believe
that that's the strategy I think the
strategy is mobilize your key
constituencies and get people out to
vote who already agree with you but that
being said I don't see any particular
advantage to the approach of if you
voted for Trump you're dumb and I hate
you for it certainly we should
acknowledge that we believed it was a
mistake it was the wrong decision but I
don't know that there's much to gain
from this general umbrella term of what
I would call vote shaming as much as it
might be the obvious visceral emotional
reaction on our side we're going to keep
talking about this and the other stories
from today's show on the david pakman
show instagram at david pakman show also
yesterday on my instagram i showed
everybody my cukes i have a whole bunch
of cucumber plants which i thought were
dead I thought these seeds are dead
these aren't going to germinate I've got
no sprouts but I have sprouts now and I
showed my sprouts to everybody yesterday
you can check it out on my Instagram at
David Pakman nothing better than a
coronavirus Victory Garden as I'm
calling it even if the victory is who's
gonna take a while to get here I check
it out we'll take a quick break and be
back after those
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com the david pakman show depends
on your support and the easiest way is
through membership which includes the
world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 welcome back
to the David Pakman show
this is super interesting and maybe not
completely surprising to you white house
data has now leaked which shows that the
White House knows that infections are
spiking in rural Trump voting areas
while they continue to decline in some
of those early hit disproportionately
urban blue voting areas and the growing
political divide that has long permeated
the country when it comes to attitudes
towards coronavirus as we know Democrats
much more likely to be taking the virus
seriously than Republicans Democrats
much more likely to be staying at home
than Republicans Democrats much more
likely to be wearing masks than
Republicans that now which has been a
political divide for some time is being
reflected in the case and death growth
rates now the trumpets will say listen
most of the deaths are still in blue
areas these liberal cities like New York
City and the surrounding New Jersey of
towns and cities Chicago Detroit Boston
now of course those places also have in
common that they are very dense cities
with huge numbers of direct flights to
and from China and Europe so that
explains why those places were early
hubs and why they were places with
significant infection early before we
had any testing and before we knew much
about the prevalence and the spread of
coronavirus but in terms of percentages
which is really where you have to look
if you want to evaluate a virus
it's called viral spread for a lot for a
reason we are now seeing that most of
those early hot spots on a percentage
basis are actually on a decline whereas
some of the fastest growth rate spots
are for example Texas Florida and
Georgia now just to put some numbers to
it check out the case growth rates
yesterday these are not raw numbers what
you want to look at is the rate of
growth which is a trajectory okay you
look at yesterday Tennessee Virginia
Texas Georgia and Florida all had
dramatically larger case growth rates
than Massachusetts and New York
Massachusetts right at one percent New
York at point four three percent
Tennessee three point five percent
growth rate yesterday and so what you
have to understand is that over time the
raw numbers are going to spike you look
at Tennessee in cases and you might say
oh okay well they went from you know 600
to 650 cases but if that rate continues
it becomes a huge hotspot very very
quickly so that gets us to this leak
data the White House has a number of
slides which have leaked that show that
this is a trend the White House is aware
of you've got rates decreasing in 14
states rates increasing in nine states
but 27 states don't even have enough
testing yet that we can say for sure
that all of the cases are even close to
being counted accurately but here's
where it gets really interesting the
state-level data may not really be
enough to underscore this dr. Burks and
others for a while now have been saying
we really need to look at counties you
need to look at counties to see what's
going on that helps to separate urban
versus rural it helps to separate parts
of states from each other it turns out
that when you look at the county level
the biggest spikes are happening in
rural Trump voting counties in places
like Kansas and Tennessee some of those
places have seen case growth rates of
more than a thousand percent in a single
week there are rural Trump counties in
Missouri
Nebraska Minnesota Wisconsin which
leaned heavily trump the counties do
where cases have grown 400% all but one
of the top ten growth counties in the
last week were trump counties in 2016
dr. john ross who's a professor at
Harvard Harvard Medical School tweeted
about the same quote the fastest-rising
areas in the US for kovat cases are very
white and very Trumpy according to this
slide somebody leaked to NBC News this
is why I do not believe that Trump's
strategy of just normalizing the deaths
and pretending we've won is going to
work it could work for some time there's
no question about it
because right now the growth rates are
very high in a lot of these Trump
counties but the raw numbers are still
small if you go from a hundred to 200
new cases per day it's a hundred percent
increase but it's still only 200 cases
it's not going to get as much attention
particularly when a lot of times people
are sorting the data by most new cases
today which will favor states with
larger populations and states with early
infections but if then you go from 200
new cases a day to 400 to 800 to 1600
and then cumulative cumulative Lee
you're talking about a huge number of
infections so what that says to me is
the Trump strategy of saying we won
we've prevailed we're on the decline
we've got testing we've got everything
the economy is going to reopen third
quarter will be transitional fourth
quarter is gonna be amazing 2020 one's
gonna be the best in history this type
of stuff it ignores that if these growth
rates continue another 30 days and we
said this 10 days ago and now a lot of
these states are the leaders in growth
rate if it's another 30 days of this you
are going to have very red states that
presumably local news is still going to
report on cases and deaths national news
is going to point to these states as the
new hot spots I don't believe that it is
viable for Trump to simply pretend
everything is fine until November if
indeed these places continue spiking
also interesting somebody leaked this
data that means that someone
inside the White House and inside or
close to the task force I don't mean
like dr. Burks but there's so much staff
that's associated they probably decided
to leak this because they realized they
need to because of what the public
position of Trump has been you see Trump
go out and say cases are going down
everywhere and then inside the task
force they have slides would say that's
not true
and the places where it's growing the
fastest or mostly Trump counties
you've got Fox News broadcasting you
know it's time to go and open and get
back to work
but a ton of their employees are still
working from home what's being said
publicly is not matching up with the
policies that a lot of places are
putting in place Trump continues to say
we don't need to worry about testing and
tracing things are good to go
everything's going down and yet the
White House over the last 72 hours has
put in place a mandatory masks policy
and daily testing for more and more
people other than Trump and pence of
course they're not wearing masks so they
are very clearly saying one thing and
doing something very different when it
comes to the policy behind the scenes
meantime I am very pleased to see that
here in Massachusetts we had very small
case growth rate for about the last 10
days deaths yesterday were at their
lowest since April 4th which is about 40
days ago Louis deaths and 40 days was
yesterday in Massachusetts that's really
really good to see and we're expecting
some new guidance probably in the next
48 hours from Massachusetts governor
Charlie Baker who's not been perfect
he's been late on a bunch of stuff but
he's been far earlier than more than
half of the country's governors we'll
see what continues to happen in the
early infection blue states like New
York New Jersey Massachusetts California
Illinois and then we're going to be able
to compare and contrast that was place
with places that never really closed at
the state level cities may have done
things and that have been very quick to
reopen we're going to know in the next
20 or 30 days exactly what the
repercussions of that are early data are
that it's not going to be particularly
pretty ok I have a Gaslight alert for
you today gas lighting is
you manipulate someone into questioning
their own ability to understand the
world and the new Gaslight phrase of the
week from the Trump administration is we
are now testing more than South Korea
per capita and this is this is going to
be a painful one because it is such
weaponize disinformation but I do think
it's important to do this this is the
anatomy of disinformation for you to
understand very very clearly so we have
a corona virus pandemic the way we find
cases is by doing tests for the virus
right now they they've all been RNA
based tests an antigen test is now in
development and may soon be available
but so far you find cases by doing RNA
tests which require a number of
different elements in order to do the
test so far so good
South Korea and the United States find
their first respective cases of corona
virus within hours of each other we
often say January 20th I think one was
January 19 the other was the 20th with
the time difference it may have been
simultaneous it doesn't matter within
hours of each other South Korea and the
United States confirmed their first case
South Korea immediately develops a test
ramp sub testing capacity tests lots of
people establishes fever clinics to
isolate people who test positive contact
traces exposed contacts of infected
people puts them in home isolation and
they do a fantastic job with the virus
all while not being authoritarians
remember South Korea is ranked higher
than the United States on the new mock
democracy index that was January now
Trump didn't do that we didn't get much
testing capacity until the end of March
which is essentially two whole months
during which South Korea developed
tested contact race etc we started to
ramp up testing at the end of March if
you looked at the numbers of tests that
we were doing in the first part of March
it was numbers like 600 tests in an
entire day we got up to a few thousand
tests per day our testing capacity was
terrible at the time we were about 50th
or 55th in the world per capita maybe
even worse I don't remember exactly now
compared our testing numbers in early
to South Korea's positive test results
by early March South Korea was finding
sometimes 800 positive cases in a day
and there was a period in early March
where South Korea was doing so much
testing that they were finding more
cases than the total number of tests we
were doing understand that comparison
there were days in early March we South
Korea and the US had our first confirmed
case on the same day days in March where
we would do X number of tests and South
Korea would have act that same X number
of positive tests because they were
doing so much more testing than us
this allowed South Korea to stop the
spread very very early now over time
during March April into May our testing
rate continued to really lag we were
testing 50th in the world you know then
45th in the world per capita then 41st
currently our testing rate is about
30,000 people per million that puts us
40th worldwide in testing per capita
this is as of a few hours ago
we are behind Singapore and Canada in
per capita testing but we are ahead of
the Czech Republic as examples and as we
were failing during March and April
reporters kept asking Trump and other
officials you keep saying we're doing a
lot of tests but what about per capita
because per capita were not it wasn't
clear whether Trump understood what per
capita meant and or was pretending not
to we didn't know the talking point was
we've done more tests than anyone in the
aggregate but of course per capita was
what was relevant at the time the new
talking point now is hey everybody's
talking about South Korea we now have
more per capita tests than South Korea
that is true and in fact our testing per
capita is now double that of South
Korea's but why is this gas lighting its
gas lighting because South Korea barely
has any cases there is no point now in
comparing us to South Korea because
South Korea barely has an outbreak at
this point in time look again at South
Korea's curve South Korea hasn't had
more than a hundred and fifty cases in a
since March 11th that's not a typo I
want to say that again
South Korea has not had more than 150
cases since March 11th in the US we
regularly have a thousand 1,500 2,000
2,500 deaths per day South Korea has not
had a day with more than 150 cases since
March 11 that's two months ago so the
point is of course our per capita
testing rate is now greater than South
Korea's they have nobody to test because
almost no one has the virus we have a
third of all the global cases South
Korea has 258 deaths total okay total
South Korea has 258 deaths the Trump
administration is now bragging that our
per capita testing rate is higher than
South Korea's but it's actually an
embarrassment it took months for us to
get our testing rate to match that of a
country that essentially eliminated the
outbreak two months ago and we are still
only 40th in testing per capita there is
no serious reason to even mention South
Korea anymore other than to say that's
what we should have done they handled it
correctly and we didn't this is the new
Trump is talking point Trump is using it
Kaleigh Mac and Anna used it yesterday
during her press briefing we need to be
testing more South Korea doesn't even
have sick people to test anymore there's
no reason to continue comparing
ourselves to South Korea at this point
South Korea is an instructive example
for what we should have done on January
20 that's almost three months ago let's
take a quick break almost four months
ago sorry let's take a quick break and
we'll be back right after this
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com the david pakman show depends
on the support of our viewers and
listeners and one way to keep us going
is through patreon where you can pledge
as little as one dollar per month or as
much as you want at patreon.com slash
david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well read about him the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
a woman is now admitting that she was
paid to lie that dr. Anthony foul he
sexually assaulted her this is the same
woman who lied that Robert Muller had
sexually assaulted her it appears that
exactly the same people put her up to it
now this story is crazy
but I actually think the context is
what's most disturbing and and
outrageous and I'm gonna explain that in
a moment but first the details woman
named Diana Rodriguez claimed that dr.
Anthony foul a the country's lead
infectious disease expert he's been on
Trump's White House coronavirus task
force he used to be a fixture at the
press briefings he testified before the
Senate yesterday Diana Rodriguez claimed
that foul she sexually assaulted her in
2014 to a reporter that reporter reasons
Nancy Rommel Minh had been working on
the story looking at the allegations
from Diana Rodriguez we've since learned
that Diana Rodriguez is really Diana
Andrade and she is actually connected to
Jacob wall a pro Trump troll who
previously tried to orchestrate
completely bogus sexual assault
allegations against Robert Muller during
the time when Robert Muller was doing
the Trump Russia investigations so once
again you've got the same people getting
caught trying to do the same thing
trying to frame a public figure that was
inconvenient I guess to the right with
sexual assault Diana
Andrade said she was paid to come
forward with the bogus allegations so
those are the simple details but I
believe that the surrounding elements
are actually what's more important here
why is anybody trying to frame an
infectious disease doctor at all
why is Rand Paul as I will soon show you
going after dr. pouchy this is actually
the story a doctor who's simply doing
his job has done it four Republican
presidents and four Democratic
presidents is trying to save lives whose
ideology
he says his health and is nearly 80
years old right I mean this guy's been
doing this for decade after decade this
diminutive 79 year old doctor has become
the enemy of the trumpet's right why is
he an enemy because he thinks he
he says things which are based in
science and medicine which sometimes
conflict with the completely fake phony
narrative that Donald Trump concocts and
creates whether it's about fact-checking
about hydroxychloroquine whether it's
about a second wave whether it's about
vaccinations whether it's about
reopening whatever it is he has been
seen dr. Fauci by the Trump astride as
an antagonist of Donald Trump when
really he is and I guess we would call
it an agonist for the truth and what
makes him invariably an enemy of the
Trump is right is that he appears to
interfere with Donald Trump's lies
imagine doing your job so well being way
more trusted by the public than Trump by
the polls show conclusively the public
by large margins trusts Anthony Fauci
on an coronavirus way more than they
trust Donald Trump and the reaction from
some is this guy's the enemy fire foul
Chi and let's get somebody to lie and
claim doctor foul she sexually assaulted
them so Jacob wall and his partner
Berkman are of course a huge part of the
problem but the hostility among the
Trump is Right hostility to science
hostility to reason and to medicine and
to doctors and to Public Health that is
really the big story here now the second
part of this is why aren't jacob
wallenberg men in prison they tried to
frame robert muller and now they tried
to frame anthony foul gee is it because
the law doesn't matter anymore at
minimum in civil court you could see
lawsuits certainly over the robert
muller allegations and in reality it's
not outrageous to think that there could
be criminal charges here and once again
our country is an embarrassment truly
they're laughing at us all over the
world Germany Spain Italy France South
Korea Taiwan they take the virus
seriously they Revere their medical
experts they do what they're supposed to
do they deal with the virus and now they
can start to reopen to different degrees
in different countries depending on
what's going on meanwhile here in the
United States people demand that doctor
foul Qi be fired ignored and that Donald
Trump be listened to and now the idea of
free
ouchy with false sexual assault
allegations is uncovered um you know I
got emails yesterday about our story the
world is is laughing at Trump and it's
really bad for us and there were people
a lot of people from Europe and other
countries who said you know David we
were laughing we're not laughing anymore
now we just feel really bad for you guys
but we also are worried for ourselves
because we're used to the US as a
productive partner in solving problems
to the extent that we've been able to
solve problems in the past and the US
isn't that anymore so there's laughter
happening but there's also significant
concern that we are just so backwards on
every single one of these elements let's
talk now about the Rand Paul story I
mentioned earlier Kentucky Republican
Senator Rand Paul yesterday went on Fox
News and he chose feelings over facts I
thought they were the facts over
feelings people Rand Paul had a very
embarrassing day in total yesterday
there had they had a Senate hearing
where dr. Fauci dr. Redfield
and others testified and Rand Paul sort
of scolded Anthony foul she's telling
him you know you're not the end-all you
just want opinion and we got to look at
what other countries are doing as well
including Sweden which we'll talk about
but then Rand Paul went on Fox News in
the evening to talk about the new
so-called Obama gate scandal this is a
totally fake trumped-up scandal to
distract from Donald Trump's incredible
failure on coronavirus and Rand Paul
asserts to martha maccallum that Barack
Obama gave direct oversight and guidance
on unmasking Donald Trump's former
national security adviser Michael Flynn
the Fox News host martha maccallum asks
the right question which is do you have
evidence of that and Rand Paul says I'm
not I'm not kidding you're gonna see
here I have a strong feeling he has a
feeling but no facts take a look at it
Trump campaign I really strongly believe
that President Obama gave specific and
direct oversight and direct permission
for this think about it we have never
allowed a secret court to be used
against the presidential can't campaign
don't you think that was sensitive
enough that it went all the way to the
very top so yeah the media have treated
President Obama with kid gloves
to ask him directly did you approve a
profit of operation crossfire hurricane
I think the answer is yes so you know I
mean you put the shoe on the other foot
a lot of use do you have evidence of
that you say you're sure that the
president the former president was
involved in this why are you so sure
well we'll find out I'm hoping that a
lot of this will be declassified but I
have a strong feeling that this was such
a sensitive subject he's already
admitted or admitted through people that
worked for him that the Flint
investigation he knew a lot about I
strongly believe I think the answer is
yes but do you have evidence well no but
I have a feeling this is downright
irresponsible for a sitting u.s. senator
to be saying if Rand Paul had a shred of
evidence for his claims he would have
provided it by now but he doesn't have
any evidence so instead he has his
feelings since when do sitting senators
go on television and accused former
presidents of wrongdoing allegedly
criminal wrongdoing on the basis of
feelings I guess now is the answer to
that so that was Rand Paul choosing
feelings over facts on Fox News earlier
in the day here is Rand Paul going after
doctor foul Qi remember that Rand Paul
got coronavirus while he was waiting for
his test results he went to the Senate
gym and worked out turns out he was
positive during that workout now he's
refusing to wear a mask and here he is
scolding doctor foul Qi during
yesterday's Senate hearing much as I
respect you doctor Falchi I don't think
you're the end-all I don't think you're
the one person that gets to make a
decision we can listen to your advice
but there are people on the other side
saying there's not going to be a serves
and then we can safely open the economy
and the facts will to bear this out but
if we keep kids out of school for
another year what's gonna happen is the
poor and underprivileged kids you don't
have a parent that is able to teach them
at home are not gonna learn for a full
year and I think you've got to look at
the Swedish model and we ought to look
at our kids get back to school it's a
huge mistake if we don't know if in the
schools in the fall thank you now Rand
Paul mentions Sweden talk about Sweden a
little bit Sweden much like chloroquine
has become a political football and for
me just like with chloroquine i have no
emotional attachment to sweden did the
right thing or Sweden didn't do the
right
thing what happened in Sweden is that
older and vulnerable folks isolated and
stayed at home but young people mostly
haven't there's been mild social
distancing in bars and restaurants
school stayed open young people for the
most part lived close to their normal
lives what do we know so far
well so far Sweden's death rate is the
ninth highest in the world
if you eliminate tiny countries like San
Marino and Andorra Sweden's death rate
right now is the sixth highest in the
world out of more than a hundred and
eighty countries so what we can say is
that so far at this point in the
pandemic Sweden's plan has led to a
really high death rate now let's be fair
does that mean
Sweden's plan failed not necessarily
because it's possible it's possible that
because Sweden is doing this and having
more a higher death rate now it could
get them more immunity and potentially
potentially Sweden could end up with
lower deaths during wave 2 and wave 3 if
there is one so I again I just want the
truth
if Sweden's plan worked then great we
should all know it if it didn't work
then we should all know it so far
Sweden's death rate is very high but if
they end up with more immunity by the
time wave two hits which could wave to
could be worse than wave one we don't
know yet Sweden may end up in the long
term for the total pandemic they could
end up with a lower death rate we just
don't know yet
now doctor foul he responded aye he also
doesn't think he's the be-all end-all
he's just a public health professional
here's how he handled it first of all
Senator Paul thank you for your comments
I have never made myself out to be the
end-all and only voice of this I'm a
scientist a physician and a public
health official I give advice according
to the best scientific evidence there
are a number of other people who come
into that and give advice that are more
related to the things that you spoke
about about the need to get the country
back open again and economically I don't
give advice about economic things I
don't get advice about anything other
than public health so I wanted to
respond to that
the second thing is that you use the
word we should be humble about what we
don't know and I think that falls under
the fact that we don't know everything
about this virus and we really better be
very careful particularly when it comes
to children so I think you get the idea
Anthony foul she not getting rattled by
Rand Paul making him the enemy I know we
talked about this but what kind of a
sick country are we that a doctor who's
been doing this for decades and has
worked for I think it's six presidents
is now the enemy bogus documentaries are
being made where dr. pouchy is the
villain people are attempting to concoct
false
sexual assault allegations against
doctor foul G as I told you about
earlier
crowds protests are screaming fire foul
Chi yesterday I did a story about the
world is laughing at us the treatment of
health experts by the Trump crowd during
this pandemic is a big part of why the
world is laughing at us absolutely sick
and a notice of course that dr. Fauci
has now been gone for weeks from any
Trump administration press briefing
coronavirus task force event he's still
doing interviews he testified before the
Senate but he has been disappeared as we
talked to you about a couple of weeks
ago we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p the
Eggman called in we haven't heard from
the Eggman much if you're not familiar
with the Eggman the Eggman is a former
federal convict who did some time for
completely nonviolent drug charges
remember that nonviolent he's a good guy
and he calls in every once in a while he
believes that Joe Biden will crush Trump
in Florida here's why he believes that
hey Dave I love what you have built
share on the guy is great he's super
smart he's dead right about Florida
Florida is definitely gonna vote by it
and over Trump I have two reasons for
this the first reason is when Trump was
in New York resident New York did not
vote for him okay but understand that
New York is far more liberal than
Florida so so far it's not a great
argument from the eggman but let's
continue who rejected him we voted
Hillary now that he's Florida's problem
as in Greta they are Florida is going to
reject Trump I'm telling you this it's
gonna yes so he may
right but Florida is just a redder state
than New York so I don't know that it's
a good comparison if you know if if
Trump moved to Massachusetts
Massachusetts isn't voting for Trump so
I don't know how much the residency is
going to be a factor okay
also my dad is an old Jew in a
retirement community and they've all
loved Biden they don't give a crap about
any allegations anything terrible who
they are voting Biden damn I have six
baby chicks that are tickin and I'm
gonna have eggs in the chicken coop this
year but sometimes one turns out to be a
rooster if I have a rooster I'm gonna
name em after you brother
David Pakman but hopefully I won't uh
Shalom brother hi pal right Shalom to
the egg man and yeah by the way the
rooster thing just reminded me I've been
getting some videos from viewers of
their pets who like watching the show so
there's a Portuguese dog I don't mean a
Portuguese water dog like the breed just
a dog in Portugal who watches the David
Pakman show
every day with rapt attention and I got
a video of it and a bunch of people have
been we're gonna do a compilation of
these if you have a pet that likes
watching the David Pakman show
please get video of it and send it to me
we would love to see it and include it
in our upcoming compilation on the bonus
show today Republicans are now trying to
win that California special election
that we've talked about many times
before I'm gonna talk to you about that
we will also talk about us grocery costs
we often talk about deflationary spirals
when we talk about recessions possibly
depressions like the one we are in or
may soon be in' but there are areas
elements of society where we have seen
significant inflation of prices
groceries are one of those areas we're
going to talk about that also on today's
bonus show the Georgia Governor Brian
Kemp now says Georgia drivers who got
their licenses without a road test are
going to have to eventually take that
road test I want to talk about where
this all came from and the implications
don't miss today's bonus show for our
members only sign up at join pakman.com
or at patreon.com slash david pakman
show
huge bonus show I will be joined by
producer Pat Forde and there will be
much discussion very much talking I will
put it that way
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's sponsor
blue chew is giving you your first
shipment completely free all you have to
do is pay five dollars shipping go to
blue to calm and use the promo code
David I've put a link right underneath
this video